what's up everyone it's time for my
favorite subreddit that is all about me
we might as well call this week
reddit week who's excited Laci content
week because I'm in Japan
let's go snow white must have been like
there it is beautiful I thought I said
these memes are about me this mean works
perfectly as well because he came back
the meme came back I don't know where
wholesome spooked Oberon has it been
three what is it four years Jesus I
still love you boots teacher the test
isn't bad confusing oh god it's a
Minecraft mean and I don't understand it
you better chosen what I am sorry I
understand now that Enderman like to
take that and that's normal I understand
what carry mas epicly [ __ ] lasagna
blink one year ago
damn has it been one year hymen is like
going forward and stuff it makes no
sense though our gamers I got a new Sun
coming and it's gonna make [ __ ] lasagna
look like a [ __ ] lasagna that's all I
can say Felix I'd freak Danny DeVito
might say who just bug creeper and dog
customs remember the baby who ate the
camera this is him now feel old yet god
damn that looks actually remove my teeth
then you got the same person
Felix thinking he became a Minecraft
veteran that one in German water me come
on
I understand that that ender might like
to make their pinky toes go people up in
the water I get it now
okay Brooke finger peep eyes minecraft
roleplay I really look forward to make
another minecraft episode
what's going on with [ __ ] I need to
fight it out guys number one thing as
soon as I get back
October 24th birthday
that's right Drake you can lick my
nipples I would like that very much
thank you I never understand the Drake
fascination liking Drake it's like
liking hot water I don't want to drink
it hot I want to drink a cold
go away hot water you're trying to be
different and I don't like it I may have
gone a little too far on that diss I'm
sorry Drake but if someone had to say it
furnace dead memes skeleton effect
spooked Auburn spooked over the month of
the year where memes we don't have to
try anymore just hide skeletons do
anything and you got yourself an epic
upvoted meme congratulations everyone my
father when I was little this is so
wholesome adults when they're paid
minimum wage kids when they're paid
minimum wage it's funny because it's
accurate
Mike Witzke Mike czarsky Mike was out
without ski that's the worst name I have
ever seen whoever made this should be
ashamed of yourself
I am down vote Felix I would free
creeper Felix I would freakin tuck Felix
I would freak Danny DeVito
Felix our frickin villager confused
artillery anymore Isis nothing
I found begs names give it back give it
back here I want I lost I didn't I mean
I didn't lose said just give it back to
me Diego the turdus had summer sex he
saved his entire species does that
species really deserve to live I'm sorry
no I'm gonna go with no on that one I
was taking a shower and didn't know I
was having a nosebleed so when I looked
down I saw a bunch of blood and I
thought I was having my period but then
I remember I'm a 16 year old asian boy
why what did I do
all played if this video gets a million
likes why do I even say these things
so guys we did it why you did it now it
took you that long
took too long I'm sorry gamers I'll
consider it if you give me back begs
nametag oh god here it is I want to see
the most illegal thing I own
stop just stop this is why 2019 is a
good year you know I've been doing
YouTube for over nine years the channel
is also nine years old
so you took a screenshot of your own
comment and posted it on subreddit well
done incredible job this feels like a
jacksFilms meme where you just keep
reposting yourself feelings I'd freaking
duck what is all this I wouldn't
actually freak attack
marzia who just received her creeper
costume hey look it's the same joke for
the fifth time Jesus Christ that one
Enderman mean Felix vet stop I'm still a
veteran because now I understand and
they're men first from time to time
likes to go in the water I'm just like
you guys I bet you can't make a furnace
from brain I bet you can't make four
chests without looking up the recipe I
bet you can make a whole girls watching
story time videos my psycho ex-boyfriend
Stuart a I broke my ass why are there no
cats on Mars because curiosity killed
them all
Ilyn I'm sorry that's a no for me alone
me open the classroom door the whole
class it's so accurate and true when
you're born in Sweden marry an Italian
woman live in England and then move to
Japan
mr. worldwide yes I have 1 million in my
army well I have 1.3 million in my army
MA
yeah come on America and China you got
nothing your PewDiePie's new minecraft
pet in 360 vir
yes i'll die they so mean for real
someone did they that's so cute feel
like starting his minecraft series be
like how do i play has drawn first blood
is on killing spree it's a rampage it's
so stoppable
it's dominating its godlike don't worry
guys i figured it out i modified my
keyboards so my dog could play Minecraft
and then spend eight hours teaching him
very epic it looks like your dog got the
hang of it
the handed microfauna looks like a paw
as well I hope you gave him the same dog
skin so what do you do on your spare
time
I'm teaching my dog how to play
Minecraft only one business in the
galaxy gets you this rich trading with
villagers I like this to me the first
person to remake their own meme must
have been like it never stops this one
does it have you guys seen the origin of
this is if it's from Giant Bomb there is
look at it with my hoe here I can kind
of tell what kind of a so what is that
oh yes a till the gray it's funny it's
funny make it laugh haha spoofed over
memes
my first October on reddit you literally
just have to go back on reddit one year
and repost all the stuff I got out
further then epic karma gamers cuz it's
the same joke every time I got a tattoo
of pewdiepies leg on my arm oh my god
that's so night guys that is I am
honored what a privilege thank you guys
so much
me and the boys at 1159 me and the boys
at 12 a.m. I don't I don't get it
freaking Zoomers taken over my subreddit
I don't understand it anymore 10 years
from now I'm gonna be like god I don't
understand like what's gonna happen with
his reddit even when I stopped doing
videos it's not gonna be pretty
oh that reminds me okay what is this how
did we get mods in this subreddit I did
not mod anyone feel free to post
whatever you want okay there's no rules
from the pewdiepie sub ready make sure
you post your memes down in below
ironically this was last time I was in
Japan ready assigned a moderator to the
subreddit people are using this clip to
kind of compose conspire against him
because I've been saying I don't I
didn't assign him or whatever and in an
ideal world there would be no moderators
and people can just post whatever they
want we don't live in ideal world gamers
I know it's sad what come back is not
real it hurts it hurts every day since
the PT I separated was so big reddit
needed and moderated for it
so they just assigned one I don't
here it saves me time apparently it's
necessary that we have one otherwise
their red it will be shut down he's done
a lot of great work to to prevent from
raids and other website influencing the
sub ready so just back off okay he's the
Mon deal with this gamers listen I don't
I don't care I don't have time to care
about ready drama this is all I'm gonna
say about it do you want to see the most
illegal thing I own
what you can't guys you can't actually
do that I'm a micro veteran that's
illegal if you do that SWAT it's gonna
SWAT your house immediately
Vsauce you might want to delete this
meme bro you might want to get rid of
this one Felix could jailbreak my said
couch Albert's husband it's me
yay me trying a new template people who
sort by new you should have done the one
where he's falling down where he's
already fallen good I gotta tell you
guys how to make memes now I'll freak
every page of Google you can't stop me
21 years age of Google Oh Google San
daisuki Dave listen kid I don't have
much time but the actual villain in
PewDiePie's minecraft series is oh my
gosh
who is it I need to know right freaking
now when the meme is dying and no one is
talking about you oh man don't care I
freaked him I'm done I don't care
anymore
I freaked I say bye-bye you can cry all
you want went all the way to Bali to get
this photo yeah okay sure that's the
only reason you way now this is an epic
gamer moment they remove the ex now it
says eat that's not epic that's not epic
at all what are they gonna take from
Sponge Bob next doom don't it spooked
over gamers dude dude what is this I'm a
man of my word I promised this to a
follower editor that means that means
that means send me stop stop
congratulating yourself Jesus Felix
rating memes in 2018 8 out of 10 this
meme gets blip
if you don't understand it the night's
your problem using Norma meme format
like Drake using you 10 ish cues dog
because he died and he's a good put all
rest in peace dog oh I can't trust if a
pet is dead thanks to the love cat meme
totin am I'm dying infinity wait can you
do that he's doing dangers to be kept
alive of a Minecraft veteran and I'm
pretty sure you can't do that
minecraft veteran status restored aha
that feels good thanks guys no I'm not
going grad laying myself I'm just saying
thanks guys when the G Falls of the
graveyard sign rave yard side my says
real sound
Felix emulating realize that your cake
day is one day before spooked Ober
realizing that somewhere in the world
it's already spooked Ober that's blow my
mind gamers if you don't understand
something stand up and ask the teacher
to repeat it if you would have been
paying attention you would understand if
you were so dumb kids plays minecraft
again not his single-player world it
will it will come very soon when I'm
back to slaving away at YouTube in UK me
knocks on door while trick-or-treating
dresses the creepers
I kind of want to dress up as a creeper
wait me and March already decided over a
dressing up s oh my god this meme sucks
Ronan really good-looking guy who has
dreamy eyes and gets all the girls he
wants Ronan Ronan stop I think this is
the case for like nearly any name on
urban dictionary
Felix has a very warm smile and deep
voice he is sunshine a Felix is very
soft person also had going the type of
guy who would want to be friends with he
also has the hue whole universe painted
on his cheeks
Felix can also flex on you on his new
minecraft skins bigger collision Felix
makes me happy he's my sunshine he'll do
for tonight dance until we break our
ankles this is it
is this complementing Felix yeah I'll do
that I'll do the template okay wait it's
like this and then the other one is like
here you go son there you go
name template for you gamers saw this
guy at the mall today what beauty pies
in real life that's awesome
wait minecraft knows Hebrew mind power
what I thought he broke with the
Minecraft and Chapman language for a
second should you fab to lego indiana
jones humanity was a mistake let's just
get real here yeah that's disgusting
I'll freak a creeper and nothing else
I'll stick to my principles but you
can't say the same Bowser Bowser
Brad Brad eight Jack Jack that's a good
one I've never heard that reports
remember him why do I keep saying
freakin what am i five freak freak freak
a freak
this is him now did I say stop freaking
keep freaking Phil gamer yet
oh damn I'm so multi-talented when a me
makes me blow air out of my nose me the
orange house button what okay so Drake
Golden Apple enchanted golden apple
they're the same meme is that what you
mean I'm so confused
oh wait okay so this mean this meme
there's a comes in no wait my brain hmm
minecraft sheeps minecraft she's with
Nick take out the Wiis oh ten out of ten
thinking that lips the choke cat died
finding out he's actually live in well
there you go
it was all for nothing our pain was for
nothing bail of authorship circuit 380
oh my god that is also what is this
PewDiePie spoilers what their shape will
rise I can feel it right freak it duck
okay not who I understand I mean I
understood before of course but now I
understand woman falls in love with DJ
who played out of her wedding wait sorry
that's hilarious what the heck is this
how to get into low I I made this 69
hours that's awesome
say the line part spooked Oh bear that
should be the official language of
October that means I'll freak a creeper
you got to make a painful voice when you
do it yeah this isn't funny
introducing the range Oh God oh whoa
downloadable map filled with beautifies
animals okay all right
each of them were obtained from his
world from their exact spawn locations
Wow Sven what there's sheep
Jurgen oh my god Bernie meaning these
are not copies they are his animals Oh
Jules wait I can bring them all back is
that what is that what is I can't bear
to hear the penguin brandon bread - oh
this is the most greatest invention of
Planet how friendship works he's an ass
I hate him I respect a bit Satan no you
are epic brah let's hang out sometime
see you in Hell Satan it's gonna be
awesome
another update Satan is in there
CaptainSparklez predicted minecraft
nether update got
oh wait oh oh my god there's two Obama's
that's why Obama Zeiss name is Obama the
second cuz there's two Obama's could
there be three Obama's I don't know for
sure there could be three Obama's ding
ding dong double morning Jack would love
this game ding ding ding tougher morning
ha ha this is awesome with me oh that's
so funny Oh brah Oh brah is that that
mother flippin hydrogen bra mixed with
oxygen bro oh is that a frickin water
molecule cuz yeah I'll frickin water
molecule I'll do it I'll do whatever
apex
come on don't lie you would frickin
water molecule as well smash like in
this video if you would break water
in-school suspension International Space
Station oh it's in school suspension my
brains so big okay so a girl posted with
emerge very epic a guy posted with
emerge girls posting with Mark guys
bursting with birds this is so sad the
laws of Reddit be a harsh mistress
spooked over rattled Specter spec table
there should be in here as well spec
toddler spec Thurber I am so freakin
high perspective a beautiful poor ugly
old then brave old ugly who called Shrek
ugly disgusting out freak Shrek I'm not
gay I'm saying I'm not saying that to
make him feel better I'm saying it oh
yeah I'll do it my brain in a test my
brain at night that is so flippin
accurate and it says a lot about our
society this minecraft mean well here we
go again what kind of person does this
on reddit this better not be posted by
Ryan no it isn't another Nathan I bought
a creeper costume and if da costume
goddamn oh it's only gonna get worse
from here I know it some say that Andrew
Garfield was the best spider-man some
say it was Tom Holland but deep down we
all know that Han Solo and Shrek have
the exact same outfit oh my god my mind
be like okay I've already uploaded this
because it's so awesome
now that peuta bought a house in Japan
after grading minecraft sword
katana sled so cool
peachy fried very cool Felix named a
truck Jurgen four years ago damn it yes
yeah damn it Jurgen why my vocabulary is
literally infinite incredible bonus
memes nine-year-olds oh I thought you
were dead
bonus meme my death was greatly
exaggerated
you can just make anything into
skeletons and get up dudes it can't be
that easy it is that easy
Spectre BRR everyone where everyone gets
uploaded how to tame a pillager in
Minecraft epically you have to get its
cross bro to break getting his crossbow
to break can take from 15 to 20 minutes
the pillager ones tame will no longer
hurt you and any other mobs
as you can see I mean survival and he
won't attack me another thing to note is
to give him a name to stop him from DS
spotting oh my god that's also I want to
do that tame a bunch of pillagers we can
make it pillage a freak chamber can
pillagers freak top comment let me know
I need to know this I remember this I
told the livestream
hey you remember to feed my dogs in 20
minutes because I knew I had to and then
everyone keeps saying feed your dog and
I'm like no shut up
Sven he's fine look at his tail sorry
these are strange times we live in
when here test so character is in a
cutscene that's funny so glad I grew up
with this and not this hey don't this
upside down pyramid Australian pyramid
story on Instagram by Doreen and dagger
so good I love this me when I realized
that it spooked over for me first in the
world because I live in New Zealand
rattled I remember the same thing seeing
all the spooked Ober Muse appear
afterwards I'm like but it no you're
late the first guy to read the letters
that the eye doctor must have been like
okay alright now we've got too far
nice looking at me from inside the
microwave you should have one where it's
all the back head and then when you flip
the magnets around and he looks at you
yeah that was funny right I'm sorry
oh here's another one pigmen big went
after you hit one by accident there it
is alright gamers happy spec tober
thanks for smashing like and also if
you're a gamer girl in one free up votes
clearly this works
check out the merch sorry guy gamers I
don't make the rules
see you guys tomorrow bye bye well you
haven't tried to Bruce emulator at City
after 50 million actress just now it's
still relevant just download it